[Musique]
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 et 10 10 minutes 10
minutes le temps d'une douche matinale
n'est ce pas dix minutes le temps de
prendre le débours je dirais un gros bug
mais dix minutes c'est aussi le temps
nécessaire ou prendre en charge ou
sauver une vie en urgence
7/10 précieuses minutes charlotte n'a
pas bénéficié
charlotte était jeune
chaleurs tu étais jeune n avait que 26
ans
challandes venait à peine d'accoucher de
deux magnifiques jumeaux de coeur donges
temps nous n'avions reçu lé fer entre la
vie et la mort
nous lui avons promis de lui sauver la
vie nous avions espoir pendant dix
précieuses minutes nous étions occupés a
établi le groupe ait un gain de
charlotte dans le but de lui ai fait une
transfusion sanguine
parce que malheureusement après son
accouchement
charlotte avait perdu beaucoup de sang
pendant 7 10 précieuses minutes
nous avons pu être habile au groupe
axonais de charlotte
nous étions sur le point de lui a glissé
cette fameuse transfusion sanguine mais
hélas c'était trop tard charlotte nous
avait laissés
charlotte était morte
vous savez ce qui est étonnant dans
l'histoire c'est qu'avant son dernier
accouchement
charlotte avait déjà eu deux enfants est
le minimum qu'on puisse avoir c'est une
femme qui a déjà couché une fois dans sa
vie c'est son groupe action gay cela
suppose donc charlotte qu'une fois dans
sa vie a déjà eu a établi son groupe
sanguin mais à cet instant t nous
n'avions aucun moyen de pouvoir remonter
des archives qui aurait pu nous
renseigner sur le groupe action gay de
charlotte nous n'avions pas pu commenter
ce résultat qui aurait pu nous aider en
urgence
pourquoi parce que ce groupe ait un gain
était peut-être rester dans des archives
dans un hôpital donné dans un hôpital x
données
je ne sais pas comme moi et comme
beaucoup d'entre nous ici je suppose
vous avez certainement eu la chance ou
la malchance de dire et d'être allé déjà
dans plusieurs centres de santé pour
vous faire prendre en charge
je dirai au moins une fois dans votre
vie vous êtes allé dans un hôpital dont
deux hôpitaux dans trois ou voir 1,4 et
dans ses différents hôpitaux
vous avez eu à chaque fois a raconté des
histoires vous avez eue a laissé des
traces et sept différentes histoires
sont rangés dans des piles de documents
ranger allègrement dans des placards
mais le drap ses clients que moyen de
pouvoir ne serait-ce qu'un moment relier
cette différence histoire retracée vos
histoires pour l'en fait qu'une d'autres
gros meudic bon moi je décide de me
faire prendre dans sa salle pendant
toute ma vie dans un seul hôpital
dès que j'ai un soucis de santé je le
rends dans un hôpital donné j'ai donc la
chance la chance de pouvoir retrouver
mon histoire en intégralité
mais ce sont sans compter avec le fait
que à chaque fois que vous rendrez dans
cet hôpital que vous avez peut-être
choisi la sage femme
l'efym hier l'ex want ou même le bnd ses
parts seront dix à quinze minutes pour
farfouiller dans les documents pour
rechercher votre dossier médical vous
pouvoir retracer voir histoire
mais cette dix minutes c'est quinze
minutes qui seront utilisés
ce ne sont que des minutes qui
s'égrènent dans le compteur contre la
mort crebassa lits d'urgence
alors nous sommes demandés comment
pourrions nous trouver un moyen de
relier les différents hôpitaux entre eux
comment pourrions nous trouver un moyen
de permettre un hôpital a carrément de
pouvoir remonter l'historique médical
d'un patient qui a été suivi a déjà d'un
patient qui a été suivi a beau mais
comment pouvait on trouver le moyen de
permettre à un médecin
ils se retrouvent devant l'impatience le
patient qui peut-être inconscient qui ne
peut pas parler comment ce patient peut
raconter à ce médecin est inconscient
son historique médical
comment se passe est inconscient de dia
son médecin je suis allergique à quels
médicaments
comment se passe est inconscient ou et
via son médecin je suis diabétique
comment ce patient inconscient aurait
dit à son médecin
je suis hyper tendu afin que le médecin
puisse tenir compte de ces éléments
après ces nombreuses interrogations nous
avons pu pour se voir dans une plate
forme une plateforme qui interconnecte
où les différents hôpitaux
une plateforme qui permet de remplacer
cette pile de documents
une plateforme qui permet à un médecin
ne serait ce pas une seconde de pouvoir
accéder à l'historique médical d'un
patient une plateforme qui permet de
race et de remplacer des carnets de ce
côté ceci grâce à un qr code
un simple code informatique ce coin
informatique contient votre nom
vos différentes informations médicales
le numéro d'un proche à contacter en cas
d'urgence
votre dossier médical vote historique
médication maintenir ses propos
ce code vous pouvez les primes et sur
n'importe quel support que vous portez
sur vous un bracelet nouvelle avoir
souvent de pâtes à coller sur votre
téléphone portable
ce vote montre sous forme de médaillon
ce n'est pas qu'un objet que vous pouvez
porter sur vous à n'importe quel moment
afin qu'un médecin puisse a cédé de
façon immédiate en urgence à votre
historique médical afin de vous donner
les soins qui vous sont adéquats soins
spécifiques à votre état de santé
notre objectif
cela pourra créer un village numérique
en matière de santé qui permet aux
différents hôpitaux à travers le bénin
le village numérique qui permet aux
différents hôpitaux à travers l'afrique
de s'interconnecter notre objectif c'est
de donner la chance à chaque béninois à
chaque africain de pouvoir avoir accès à
une meilleure qualité de soins ceci
grâce à son unité médicale universelle
merci
[Applaudissements]